even though matching has been studied so
extensively and there are so many from
so many facets and so many very
important results
there are some very important questions
still open about magic
one of them is approximately count the
number of matchings in perfect matchings
in a non-bipartite graphite you can do
it through jerem Sinclair begoda
and the other is is matching in
deterministic NC
so I would say these two are probably
the two of the handful of uh
outstanding big open problems in exact
algorithms
so
um
so yeah let's go to part two where I'll
uh
I'll describe the MBA algorithm
and as I said I will I will give you all
the graph theoretic definitions and show
how that leads to a proof of this
algorithm and also uh talk about the
question that was asked I think by you I
don't know who uh about the
synchronization which is coming up in a
moment
so
the me algorithm runs in phases in a
phase a maximal set of destroyed minimum
length augmenting parts
with respect to the current matching m
is found
and it should be found in order M time
which means that we do
constant amount of work per Edge and
then we are allowed to use some data
structures actually we'll
which will be we'll need
and
but none of that can be also subsumed in
order M time
so
uh again recalling the even level odd
level of a Vertex is the length of the
minimum even an odd length alternating
path from an unmatched vertex whichever
gives it the minimum
to be Infinity if none
and Min level and max level are the
smaller and the larger of even level and
odd level
the bipolar case we will search
simultaneously from all unmatched
vertices
but in the examples I will typically
have only one on Match vertex
to illustrate everything almost unless I
have to show you an augmenting path
so
again a prop
and Edge is a prop
if one endpoint is a predecessor of
other that means this gives if you give
V its Min level minimum level the
smaller of even level and odd level
and an edge is a bridge if it is not a
prop and a bridge assigns max levels
like we saw and I'm going to show it
again so in this graph
this is the unique Bridge all the other
edges are props and the props give Min
levels to all these vertices and the
bridge gives max levels to these four
vertices the fives and the sixes right
and
and I'm going to talk about this
triangle that I put up last time at the
end of the last talk that I'm going to
Define so I've defined Bridge completely
graph theoretically
right because prop has been defined
it's something that Define gives a Min
level
the last Edge should be
the last The Edge this Edge should be
the last Edge on a Min level path
whenever that happens then this Edge is
a prop
and if an edge is not a prop it's a
bridge by definition
not every bridge gives max levels to
something and we'll see why
I don't know okay so tenacity
has been defined for vertices it will
also be defined for edges and this is a
central
lotion these two that hold together
these three important concepts of of
bridge Blossom and bass which are have
to be completely graph theoretically
defined and you may ask why graph
theoretically it's so much harder and
I'll give a justification for that also
Okay so
uh this I already defined tenacity of a
Vertex is the sum of the even level and
odd level by definition
and here these four vertices in this
Blossom have finite tenacity namely six
plus three five plus four and so on
and and like I said in the last last
talk that if you take an
odd level path to this vertex and an
even level path to this vertex and
concatenate them you'll get some kind of
a lollipop and that lollipop is the same
lollipop you get for each of these
vertices
and that's why they have the same
tenacity
and and so these four have
30 internationally these purples have 50
interesting and the yellows have
17 tenacity and now I'm going to define
the tenacity of an edge
so again it's a question of of enclosing
the edge in a lollipop okay so so if the
edge is unmatched then you would like to
come to its two endpoints with with even
level paths
to get an alternate the lollipop has to
be alternating
so these are the two endpoints of this
Edge you want to come with an even
length path there and an evil length
path and and concatenate those two parts
together with that edge
that's the the lollipop that defines the
tenacity of this Edge or this Edge or or
any Edge
and so the tenacity of an edge is
defined to be the following if UV is
unmatched then it's the even level of U
plus the even level of V plus one
one for the edge itself
and if it's a matched Edge then it's the
odd level of U plus odd level of e plus
one right is that okay
again feel free to ask
any number of questions
Aaron you always have a question not yet
okay
so these are
nasty nine edges right
for example what's the tenacity of this
Edge it's the even level of this plus
the even level of this plus one so it's
the same lollipop that gives it its
tenacity even though this vertex is not
of finite tenacity
odd level is infinity so
early yeah
is associated with the node not with an
end both
I already defined the tenacity of a of a
node this way
of an edge it's defined uh in two ways
depending on whether the edge is
unmatched or matched and it's always
trying to put that edge in an
alternating lollipop
okay so also and and that's what will do
it because if you come here with an even
length path
take this Edge and go back with an even
length path you'll get an alternating
lollipop if you come here with an odd
length path take this match test and go
back with an online path you'll get a
lot an alternating lollipop
the green ones and here these edges
green are nasty 13 the purple R tenacity
15 and the yellow art nasty 17 and and
I've also marked the vertices with their
tenacities the the colors
right so these are like absolutely the
key
Notions everything else big sits on that
okay so right away let's stop talking
about the algorithm two main ideas
double diff research which I showed in
the last lecture and a precise
synchronization of events and that means
a lot of things and I'll say slowly
slowly what all it means so half this
talk is about this aspect this is
already done
this aspect and the other half is about
how to get these graph theoretic uh
definitions and prove
the algorithm correct and why graph
theory is needed graph Direct in where
graph theoretic invariance rather than
algorithmically defined Notions
so it has a
an outline of the algorithm the main
routine which is a an intertwined
breadth research with double defer
searches and that's a mouthful so let's
tear away some part of it
and I'm just gonna look at this top part
which assigns Min levels in the non
bipartite case but actually this is the
same thing that we did in the bipartite
case when we were looking for shortest
augmenting paths in a bipartite graph
remember we were searching with search
level I from zero looking at unmatched
edges then matched edges then unmatched
edges and and giving a level of I plus 1
each time when we found you know new
vertices
this is exactly what we we did in the
bipartite case
so this remains
this remains here
this remains within the non-bipedite
case but just to assign Min levels
okay
but we also have to assign max levels
and that involves running double diff
research on bridges of tenacity at
search level I this is the precise
synchronization of events at such level
I run double default search on every
bridge of nasty 2i plus 1 to find all
vertices of tenacity to I Plus 1.
whether or not we'll find all vertices
whether we'll know what all bridges are
those are questions still to be answered
right but this outline is okay
and and when I say uh
search from all vertices of level I
I mean that if I is odd these are
vertices with odd level I if I is even
then these are vertices with even level
I and whether you search along the
unmatched Edge or the mashed Edge
depends on all the parity has to be
correct and that's the same as bipartite
case in this out here
okay
Okay so
so here this is the bridge of tenacity
nine
uh so if I want
to find
at what search level will we do double
search on this at such level four
because two times four plus one is nine
and at first level four we find this
bridge we find its tenacity and then we
do double diff research to find uh these
other vertices and give them their max
levels
okay
the max level will always be 2i plus 1
minus the Min level because the tenacity
these vertices that we encounter will
all be of tenacity to I plus one we know
they're Min level so we can subtract and
get their max levels but are we sure
we'll find we when we hit a Vertex or be
sure it's of tenacity 2i plus 1 and not
less or more that's the big question
so
uh the question is what is it
take to prove this kind of a scheme
and the answer has to be induction that
if you did everything correctly up to
such level I then on search level I plus
one also you'll do things correctly and
what does it correctly mean well Min
must
for men it's very easy to see that this
scheme works because
the agent that assigns Min level to a
Vertex is one of its neighbors namely a
predecessor
right and the predecessor must have a
level of eye if it's assigning a level
of I plus 1 to this I'm not talking
about parities priorities take care of
themselves even odd and all that
right so you must have a level of eye
and has a level of I been assigned to
you well if I is the Min level of you
yes
because of the way the Min is structured
what if I is a max level of V in that
case the Min level of of U is only less
than I I minus 1 or less
so it's nasty it's 2i minus 1. so it has
been assigned a max level also in the
previous search level in the max of the
previous search level so if everything
happened correctly up to search level I
minus 1
if you follow this recipe and we can
prove that we followed it to the dot
then everything will be done correctly
in this search level also as far as Min
is concerned
okay
but what about Max
so for the case of Max the max level
is given by a bridge sort of given by a
bridge Which is far away from the vertex
it could be arbitrarily far away because
it could be a very long skinny Blossom
right
and and so the following questions arise
is there such a bridge
which will assign V its max level and
what does such mean we have to Define
that
right and will it be found at the
correct time so that Max is assigned
this V gets its max level right these
are the natural questions that arise
you have a question
what's the max
these are clearly the two questions
we are currently not diving into how the
like the running time complexity yet
of course that will be the main story
but uh for now yeah
yeah
are you okay with these two basic
questions we have to answer these right
otherwise we cannot even give a proof
through induction
so and again if you come back to these
and and and and and
so I was thought of saying that the
blossom is defined through the bridge
and I was saying it's an approximate way
of looking at things just to get things
going
and the real story is that a blossom is
a function of what tenacity and bass
and I have to define the base of a
Vertex this is also a graph theoretic
definition of base of a Vertex not
algorithmic okay how do we Define the
base of a Vertex and that is needed to
define a blossom
so and this is a mouthful this
definition is takes a fair amount of
things to get to it so let's
Take It Softly and first start of
talking about the significance of Base
okay if this is a vertex then that's its
base and what's happening with this base
the base is present on every even level
V and odd level will be path on every
one of them at least in this simple case
you can see that odd level B and even
level B and the base is always present
and this is always true
okay and the tenacity of bass is
strictly more than that nasty of the
vertex this is also a fact here tenacity
of this vertex is infinity because its
odd level is infinity there's no odd
path from F to this guy
right
and this is also a fact
so here is
software a starting definition and we
will
we will add more body to it uh in a
moment and I don't want to start with
all the paraphernal and and then come to
the main I want to go come to the main
point and then add the the extra stuff
around it slowly slowly so
so how what's the base of a Vertex say
that this vertex is of nasty T and let P
be an even level or odd level uh V path
starting at unmatched vertex F let's say
and assume that the tenacity of this
vertex is strictly smaller than the
tenacity of f
unmatched vertices have the highest
tenacity because and that the tenacity
of an unmatched vertex is either
Infinity or this the length of the
shortest augmenting path
including that unmatched vertex
and if you look at all unmatched
vertices and look at the one that has
the shortest smallest tenacity that's
the length of the minimum augmenting
path
obviously right
so
for this path I'm going to define the
base of V yeah yeah so an unmatched
vertex even it could have just have a
Min level and the max level could be
Infinity right it could be Infinity
do we say that tenacity is infinity or
do we say it's um left is infinity it's
even plus odd but but you want to we
want to find this small but I'm trying
to nasty of V is smaller than this the
tenacity of V is finite
whose base we want but okay if you hold
on for you will get a very precise
answer to your question when I when I
complete the picture because I'm going
to the center of the picture and then
when I put the periphery stuff around it
it'll become complete so
take this path even level or odd level
and let b v p be the highest vertex on
this part so look at the path going from
F to V and F is of course of tenacity is
strictly bigger than t
now look at the tenacies of all the
vertices on this path are they smaller
than t or bigger than t or equal to T
now the ones that are bigger than T find
the one that's highest on this path
and call that vvp
okay so on this path the highest vertex
of strictly higher tenacity than t
and then look at all possible even level
and odd level B paths t
and look at this entire set of bvps over
all such paths
how big do you think that set is
you see what I'm doing
uh so huh sorry it's one so so I'm
looking at we
and looking at an even length path and
then looking at an odd suppose order
level is bigger than uh bigger than even
level and all these paths
so all of the odd level paths will be of
the same length all of the I'm just
drawing them at their sheer edges of
course
and here they are and and each time I'm
putting a cross on the highest vertex of
tenacity strictly bigger than t bigger
than T bigger than T of course f is
bigger than T but that may not be the
highest vertex of tenacity because
anything
okay and I'm collecting all of these
vertices
highest vertex of tenacity bigger than t
I am forming that set
and I want to claim that that set is a
Singleton like he said why why do you
think it's a single turn
well I think it's gonna be that's what
you're looking for right that's going to
be the um base right
so this bbp is independent of P there's
only one such vertex and that will be
called the base
for B
so that's a graph theoretic fact
okay
um
towards the end of the talk I'll give
you a challenge
to prove this theorem
by itself I don't see how to prove this
theorem by itself standalone
I only know how to prove this theorem
along with five other theorems
through a very massive induction that
uses all the facts together all at once
and keeps building through induction all
the all the assertions
okay
but we'll come to that
any questions to see so
okay and so this is this is called the
base and B is called a basal vertex
these are special vertices
this will be the basis of blossoms okay
and of course the tenacity of the base
by definition is strictly bigger because
you these are of nasty strictly bigger
than t
okay
clean clear okay
so so let me finally
get this assumption out that rasterity
is strictly smaller than tenacity of f
what is tenacity of f can we allow
Infinity tenacity in F Okay so
uh
I don't know that I should get here
I'll come back to these so
to come to that the periphery that I was
talking about
I need to show you
that a vertex of tenacity so LM LM is
the length of a minimum length
augmenting path
so by definition it is take all
unmatched vertices look at their
tenacities
and take the Min of these that is the
length of the minimum length augmenting
path
right
easy to take all unmatched vertices look
at their tenacities and sort them by
Dynasty and take the smallest one that's
the length of the shortest augmenting
path I'm calling that length Ln
and I'm asking this question if if a
Vertex is of tenacity LM can it does it
have have to have a base and the answer
is no for instance in this graph in this
graph these all the vertices have
tenacity 3 which is Ln
and the tenacity of the base has to be
strictly higher
right
but remember what's the purpose of the
base it it is present on all e even
Lebanon odd level pass to the V to the
vertex
and why doesn't this vertex serve that
purpose because it is on the odd level
path and the even level path so why
don't we call this the base of V even
though it's tenacity is the same as the
left your V
well this is a picture is a bit
deceptive because as soon as I add this
Edge which doesn't change the tenacity
of any vertex
I get an odd level pass from here odd
level paths from here even level pass
from here even level path from here and
even level path from here so so this
this cannot be the base even by any any
other definition
right
so so this is about
the bound and and and now I need to
define the notion of eligible eligible
tenacity so LM is the length of a
minimum augmenting path TM is the
tenacity of a minimum tenacity vertex
among all tenacities there must be a
minimum look at that
and and an odd number which lies between
TM and strictly less than LM is called
eligible tenacity
and vertices of eligible tenacity have
basis
and are precisely the set of vertices
which will be in blossoms that are
defined from the point of view of
minimum length of alternating paths
so once I Define blossoms you'll see
that these vertices of eligible tonight
so if I had to Define base again
full force I would Define eligible
tenacity then Define take a vertex of
eligible tenacity and and do go through
these motions
to define the base
first Define only for what is the
eligible tenacity
and once base is defined
this is what it gives it allows us okay
we won't do this divide and conquer
because we have no time to waste around
on even divide and conquer but basically
if if it found any shortest even level
path even length path from F to the base
and a shortest path from base to V
of either parity starting with an
unmatched Edge
then they will be meeting only at B
so in other words this shortest path
from B to V starting with an unmatched
Edge cannot hit this this stem it is it
meets this this stem only at B and so
you could have found this path and that
path independently and stuck them
together you would get an even level
path or an odd level path so the base is
some some sense
allows you to divide do divide and
conquer though we will not use this fact
conceptually this this is this is true
and this is an important theorem for the
structure that I'm talking about
but it's not
for an algorithm
okay so so basically this vertex has
this base because every even level V and
odd level B path goes through this
vertex
this is a purple vertex it has higher
tenacity than green the purple vertices
have this as base
and it's a vertex of tenacity uh yellow
Which is higher
and so this is the base square of V
and that's the base cube of e and these
are called the iterated bases of the
vertex and this will be an important
notion later
to it will come about towards the end I
I'll bring it bring it up bring it back
so we already answered this question
so uh remember we defined outer and
algorithmically for Edmonds algorithm
here we can Define it graph
theoretically so vertex is outer if its
even level is smaller than odd level and
inner otherwise and a basal vertex is
always outer so it's even level is
smaller than its odd level which is here
Infinity
uh
so this base this base and this base are
all outer vertices they're even level
smaller than the odd level
and the blossom again has two functions
just like Edmonds
in advance it gives the other level
right to make inner vertices outer and
here it gives max levels and it hides
complexity in the case of Edmonds it
contains uh the shortest even length
path either going clockwise or
anti-clockwise and to the outside world
it looks just that macro node looks like
just like a node
here also Blossom Heights complexity
because it contains all shortage paths
from B to vertices in the blossom
shortage Parts just like I had said
earlier right so this is similar to
admins but there are two differences one
of course is this is a definition from
the Viewpoint of minimum length and two
what I'm going to Define in the next
slide is a Blossom from a purely grass
theoretic perspective not an algorithmic
perspective like Edmonds
so it'll be a mouthful so please be
ready
so here's a recursive definition of a
blossom so let B be an outer vertex
whose tenacity is bigger than T where T
is some odd number of eligible tenacity
and
the blossom with base B and tenacity T
is the following set
if T is one it's empty set
assume that blossoms of tenacity T minus
one two are already defined smaller to
nasty then the and let s be those
vertices
T and whose base is B
right we know what it means to say that
a base of a Vertex is d
then the blossom of
with base B and tenacity is all these
vertices and all the smaller blossoms
sitting at these vertices
smaller by smaller I mean of tenacity T
minus 2.
okay
Mr Right are you happy with that
this might be important right
sorry
sure okay so so here um
what is the blossom of tenacity green
with this base
it's the four green vertices right
what's the blossom of tenasty purple
which means 15 with this base
it's the purple vertices plus this sub
Blossom because it's a sub Blossom
sitting on this purple vertex
what's the blossom of tenastic green on
this base
huh
sorry
empty set because no green vertex has
this as a base
what's the blossom of nasty yellow with
this base it's a yellow purple and green
so that defines blossoms that defines
nesting of blossoms one Blossom is
nested in the other if it's a subset
and the point is that a bridge does not
define a blossom so for instance here
here we have two Bridges optimistic 11
and and this whole thing is a blossom
other than this unmatched vertex this
whole thing is one blossom
okay
with capacity 11.
so the blossom of Base B and tenastic
green is this
the whole thing
same same here so there's very little
difference between these two even though
they look quite different
uh Blossom of nasty green and this base
is just these two
nasty green and a nasty purple and base
b is all four
because this is sitting on the base and
then these are the the the base of of
these purple vertices is this guy far
away
there's no purple vertex on the way it
doesn't have to be
you see what's happening here something
very funny very strange because this
vertex is is predecessor of this this is
producer of this this is predecessor of
this this is a predecessor of this right
these are giving Min levels so this
vertex is spreaded as a star if that's a
recursive definition predecessor start
of this and yet this is uh not a
predecessor not a prop this is the
bridge of tenacity 13
and so in this case we have a blossom
with this base and nasty seven and
Blossom with this base and tenacity 13
is all these vertices
question Aviv
so the
pictures are done by yeah mid-level Min
level yes always mid-level
farther to
unmatched edges next to each other that
go from one
line but this is the alternating part
I'll have to think about it yeah
okay so where blossoms are well behaved
in that sense that they form a laminar
family
Blossom's height complexity just like
Edmonds but but we can give stated very
formally uh basically I don't want to do
that
because you already know what I'm about
to say here
and
and then three tasks which have to be
done in uh in order a constant time per
Edge Plus some data structure work
Okay so
first is forward search which is
alternating breast research plus double
diff research to Mark predecessors and
Blossoms and assign even an odd levels
and then once you find augmenting path
to find that
what does it take and then to erase
judiciously if there's no augmenting
path
okay so marking Blossom so pass can be
found quickly so what does it take to So
eventually when we find a blossom we'll
have to find a path through it again we
are allowed only constant amount of work
per Edge
okay so if we go through a blossom again
and again the same Edge again and again
that's not allowed
each Edge can be looked at only a
constant number of times so let's see
what it takes so at such level four
we will find that black Edge and marked
it five
five
and this black Edge will also be found
because from here we search along this
Edge from here also this Edge and that's
the bridge
okay
and and so it's it it indicates uh that
that there's a blossom and that's the
that's a blossom load that's put here
when you do double reference search and
find this base
and it points to the base
and all the vertices of the blossom
point to this node and this node points
to the two peaks the red Peak and the
blue Peak remember there was a red tree
and a blue tree in the double diff
research
and the and the trees were looted at the
end points of the bridge
that's why we are pointing to here
because because when we need to find a
path through the blossom
we need to come to the root of this and
find a path in this red tree or the or
the blue tree appropriately
and then what happened the search level
five we find this Edge which is a bridge
and that creates another blossom and
this node is part of that Blossom this
is the base of the small Blossom but it
belongs to the big blossom
and so on
foreign
and and and then again there's a
distinction between graph theoretic and
algorithmic notion yeah so
we have nested blossoms we don't add
pointers to the higher level blossoms
for let's say the node from the base to
the but not say to the normal number no
no we will we will jump inside we we
don't if you don't add one yeah if you
yeah you cannot even add too many nodes
in that same time
so uh again uh there are algorithmic
Notions and graph theoretic Notions and
and the algorithm notion here is that of
a petal or and a bud so we these two
Bridges can be you can do a def research
on this in an arbitrary order say we do
this then this then we'll create a petal
node here and then we'll create a petal
node here
and and and and and this will this will
be a bud and the butt of butt of Bud
but star will be the base
and the union of the petals will be the
blossom as it should be right
in any flower
[Music]
I said what is what will will this
scheme work
will Max assign max level okay
so I said what is the agent that assigns
max level it's far away
and there were these two questions oops
sorry what is this oh oh I'm standing
right here that's the reason
and these two questions come up does it
for this vertex to get its max level
there's a certain bridge that gives it
its max level
what is such a bridge and will it be
found on time what does it mean such a
bridge okay so so for this purpose let
me Define the support of a bridge let UV
be a bridge of tenacity t
then its support is all vertices of
tenacity such that there's a Max Level
path to that vertex containing this Edge
okay
so what is the support of this there are
three Bridges here green purple and
yellow what's the support of this all
vertices such that there's a Max Level
path
to them
which contain all vertices of nasty
green which are such that there's a Max
Level path containing this bridge
so there's a Max Level path containing
this bridge like this like this so these
four are the support of the green bridge
the purple vertices are the support of
the purple bridge and the yellow
vertices are the support of the yellow
Bridge
you have a question
which one which one the one we're in one
of the pictures so in this picture when
you go up a left
also you're on an alternating path right
right
and one of the other pictures it looked
like you were going up a level yeah but
because you were uh
you have two two black edges like this
is what was different yeah yeah you're
right it might be it might not be
exactly admin level there you're right
you're right you're right there's a
reason to stretch out some edges
they're not they are arranged by mid
level but but the the Min levels have to
be pulled apart
yeah thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you
okay so now this Edge is not a prop
right the these these vertices get their
Min levels from somewhere else
it's not a prop it's a bridge what's the
support of this bridge
nothing because it doesn't give it's not
on uh on uh on a Max Level path to
anything or this bridge
its support is is empty but you would
not know that your support is empty
until you do double reference search on
it and and arrive at the bottom here
without finding anything new
so
so here's why graph theory is needed so
let V be a vertex of tenacity
then we have to show that V is in the
support of a
of a bridge of tenacity
right so so let me be a vertex of nasty
T and P be a Max Level path to V
and this theorem says that there is a
unique Bridge of tenacity on P
so that if you did double diff research
on that bridge you will reach V
and therefore every vertex of tenacity T
has a bridge that will give it its max
level that's what our
that's what was needed to show that
every every vertex of
which has a certain max level there's a
certain bridge that that will always
give it that max level and that's the
one that sits on the max level path
and this is a purely graph theoretic
fact this is there's no algorithm fact
here this is a graph theoretic fact you
have to prove it graph theoretically
and this is like one of the last facts
that needs to be proven after
they can be proven only after you know
base Blossom bridge and everything
and tenastis okay so so that was the
question to the first answer to the
first question
there's such a bridge even exist what
does it means such a bridge but will it
be found in time
and that comes to this question of
synchronization of events and here I
have a lot of ideas to show
and depends on how much energy everybody
has
so shot you have tons of energy so
intuitively your higher like the two
highest vertex vertices will form the
bridge
yeah but will you find that bridge on
time will you find this vertex on time
will the synchronization will work out
the way it was given here namely
at such level I will will you find every
bridge of tenacity 2i Plus One will you
find all vertices of tenacity 2i plus
one these are Big Short theorems right
they're not trivial facts to prove
how do we prove those things
and different parts will give rise to
different Bridges so depending on which
order in which which order you always
can actually
we always process Bridges by tenacity
right but you said uh
once you pick a Max Level path yeah then
you get a bridge a unique bridge on
every max level path there is a bridge
but the bridge that was just to show
existence right
that was just to show existence
Aaron are we fine
yeah
so it depends on how much depth we want
I can go deeper and deeper and deeper
and deeper
so basically remember this Edge from
higher to low was useless in bipartite
because because this path will be longer
than the minimum length path
right
and I said that in MV this edges that go
from high to low will be useful
why well look at this
this goes from high to low is it useful
it doesn't seem useful right now why
should be it be part of a minimum
augment alternating path right if I can
go like this I can equally go like this
well because there may be more things
here
like this
okay and so so this this Edge is the
only way
to come around
to these guys here with max level parts
how do you get to a Max Level here
you have to uh sorry sorry excuse me
these this bridge is the only way to
come to a Max Level path to these guys
or to these guys to these guys because
you've come around like this
it's not useless at all very useful
right
this is the alternating path that gives
max level to these guys
and this is the alternating part that
gives the max levels to these guys and
it uses this bridge which goes from high
level to low level which was useless in
the bipartite case
and this kind of bridge is special
and I'm going to call it an anomaly
Bridge because when you find it
if nasty is not known because the even
level of this vertex is not known
because the tenacity of this bridge is
the even level of this plus even level
of this plus one the even level of this
vertex is not known
and whether it will get a finite even
level later
nobody knows and Depends also on how big
a blossom it gets put in it could be an
arbitrarily long Blossom giving it an
arbitrary large capacity we'll get to
know it about it in the future sometime
so that's why it's called an anomaly
Bridge
okay
okay and then there's this entire
question of synchronization
which is many different ideas
uh
I don't want to uh
I don't want to go into it unless unless
there is still horsepower left somewhere
I have but
25 more
we don't need more but do do we have
half horsepower for 25 minutes because
I've already done one talk so
how many people are interested in
knowing knowing this fact
this bridge is of tenacity 11. why
because that becomes clear that when we
shrink this Blossom we're not shrink but
find this Blossom because it gives an
even level of 8 to this so this bridge
has to nasty 11 4 plus 8 plus 1 which is
11. right
and so the uh
right 13 oh 13 uh yes yes yes yes but
it's the it's the bridge of Tennessee 11
which will reveal its its tenacity right
good good for your own on on with this
right good that that now I am more
confident about moving forward because
even more yeah okay so it's after nasty
certain as you said
the question is
we will find it's nasty at such level
five when we find this blossom
and so the and and the algorithm says
that double def research on it should be
done at at first level six because
that's 13 minus one over two
and if you do that we will assign these
max levels to these guys
but the question is we found its
tenacity at search level five why don't
we do double reference such as such
level five itself
okay in other words break the rules of
synchrony that were laid out
what will go wrong I'll show you exactly
what will go wrong
okay is that is it okay
so here's what will go wrong
so let's uh
see a slightly bigger example
so the first this uh this bridge of
tenacity 11 is found and processed
at first level five and it assigns a a
an even level of eight here and this
bridge gets tenacity of 15 it is not an
anomaly because at that moment it's uh
it's found its tenacity is known you
don't have to wait for the future even
though it's going from high to low
the question is can we process it at
such level six rather than at first
level 15 minus one over two which would
be seven
what goes wrong if you process it at
search level six
the following goes wrong so at such
the following goes wrong because if we
process it at search level six
okay
and process this bridge before this
bridge which is also be processed at
search level six because it's 13 minus
one over two
it will give the masteries of 15 to
these two vertices which is wrong
because these two vertices actually
should be getting their tenacity from
this bridge and should be getting a
tenacity of 13.
so what went wrong why why was it I mean
we could have done double defel search
on this and she came down here and
labeled it 15 that was wrong
what about synchrony
is it that is making it work
the point is that
that at such level seven
so when we when we do double diff as
such on this
we there's a certain prerequisite all
lower tenacity vertices should already
be in blossoms because when we reach our
vertex we should be sure that that it'll
it should get this tenacity and not a
lower one because we don't have to have
time to look around and see oh can it
get a lower tenacity and if you have
found lower tenacity vertices already
and they are already in blossoms then
when you come here you'll skip down to
the base of that Blossom right away and
not give nasty 15 to these guys that's
what is the and and the whole point is
that you have only constant time
available per Edge and so when you reach
your vertex and give it a certain
tenacity you should be sure that it
should be deserving a lower tenacity
through some other Bridge
okay and that's what's precise
synchronization of Juventus okay then
I'm almost done basically suppose you
come down here and you have you have
this structure already there's this this
Blossom this Blossom and this is this
contains both this this is a bigger
Blossom which contains both of these
smaller blossoms so there are Blossom
nodes here and you jump like you keep
jumping blossoms to come to the lowest
base at the moment possible
who's gonna pay for all this work
if you keep coming over and over again
here
you find bigger and bigger blossoms up
there and you keep coming down these
these pointers who's going to pay for
all that work
so here we need data structures because
this is Union fine basically
and either you can use the pointer model
and incur an alpha alpha Factor more
or
you can use a result of governance
showing that in a ram model itself all
of this can be done in linear Time by
using the ram as a table lookup
or
you can try to prove a fact
that is claimed in our paper but never
proven that if you happen to do this
much work more than linear work then you
have that many more edges to charge that
work to
because if you did all of that work the
graph has to have more it cannot be a
tiny sparse graph it has to have more
edges and all of that can be charged
there
that's an obviously that there should be
those edges uh but who can prove it I I
don't have the energy or the desire to
prove that having spent 40 years on this
already so so gabo and targin will
suffice for this
okay so we have these three parts and
and finding the path is easy you you you
you jump to the end points of the bridge
and and find paths like that by
following the the blue tree and the red
tree
and the last thing is you have to
judiciously erase that means you have to
erase the path and then erase keep
erasing vertices that don't have
predecessors
okay and and the following question
comes up after you do all this erasing
how do you know that there won't be a
half eaten Blossom left
so some you ate up some part of a
blossom sum up but still remains
and because it's not a complete Blossom
no guarantees on what paths it can be
part of
how are we going to find paths through
this half half eaten blossom
and here more structural properties come
in namely
the base is the predecessor of a
predecessor of all vertices in the
blossom so if base goes the entire
Blossom goes furthermore
furthermore
these iterated bases occur on every
minimum length path even level as well
as odd level so a since the iterated
bases occur or the biggest Blossom goes
away so once you do the topological
arrays there are no half eaten blossoms
left
so so the once you do the erase your
back to the same kind of properties
as to when the first part was found so
you can go back and find the next PATH
and the next PATH erase next PATH erase
next PATH and be done
okay so the question is why did the
proof take so long
that's the obvious question
and and so as if you if you if you saw
the structure
to define a blossom you first need to
define a base
but to define a base you need to show
that the set of bases is a Singleton
but to show it this is single time you
have to go back to smaller blossoms of
smaller tenacity and its properties
okay and so there's a big chicken and
egg problem here
and in fact
this this theorem which I said that that
bbp is independent of p and that this
set is a single pen I challenge you to
prove this statement by itself I I I
don't see that it can be proven by
itself the only way it can be proven is
to prove all of these facts and all the
other facts all at once
through an induction on tenacity
okay so in the induction step you prove
all the facts about the next higher
tenacity the next higher tenacity and so
on
and even that's not enough in terms of
ideas
why because
crafter is very very complicated
everybody knows that and if you want to
trace single paths and start talking
about this fact that this set is a
single turn and talk start talking about
all these paths and with their arbitrary
intersections
it's a big spaghetti that is cannot can
never be unraveled
and the big idea that came
finally in the in recent years was to
use the power of double def research for
arguing about these things instead of
arguing about individual paths because
double deaf research has given me very
specific properties about the the
bottlenecks and and and moreover double
def research can be made to work on on
simple graphs layered graphs that are
derived from G
and once the facts are proven on that
simple layer graph they can be ported
back to the original
graph okay so that's that's what it took
I mean this this idea may have never
come
except that I was giving so many talks
about this that I had to
I had to break down double diff Research
into search into its lowest elements and
once I did that I saw that it could
actually be used for a proof not just
the algorithm and that's counter
integral right why should double diff
first search which is a graph search
method be useful for a proof it should
be used in the algorithm but it's the
central thing in both
and so this is the main algorithm
of course
and then there are pieces of it
marking up blossoms finding paths
through those blossoms by jumping to the
bridges and erasing appropriately those
are all easy pieces and I claim that
this is also very simple
and that's the whole point that the
algorithm is so simple but the structure
is so complex
I haven't even started drawing the
complex things yet
but you can imagine when you put on many
many more edges how complicated these
these blossoms could be
so uh folks here have improved the
running time of flow and bipartite
matching to almost linear time
but General graph matching Still Remains
at the same 43 year old bound
and who knows which if it will ever be
improved
has a nice Blossom for you for paying
attention thank you
[Applause]
for a few questions any questions
very nice introduction and sort of a
good overview of this group so maybe
because we didn't go into I mean it's
the first time I'm seeing double depth
first search so is it possible for you
to give us a
abstract view of what properties doubled
up for search provides in terms of
labeling or these bottleneck nodes
that's a good question so
in the paper I call it a double diff
ddfs guarantee
just look that look at that uh I I had
flashed up a slide but it'll take a
while to go back to that slide but but
ddfs at the end of it gives you a ddfs
grantee namely
you have two endpoints right of the
bridge it's and you have a red tree and
a green tree and it says that if you
take any vertex in the red tree
then there's a path
which you can find by going to the root
red root and doing search in that red
tree
you'll find this vertex and a completely
destroyed path obviously from the blue
tree root in the blue tree and because
this is a red path and this is a blue
path they are disjoint and that's what
you want to destroy pass one going into
the vertex itself one going to the base
or in case you have an augmentation then
two digit and pass one red pass and one
blue path that's the ddfs guarantee
period and the ddfs guarantees that it
will find the lowest base
right
and that latter one is what is used in
the proof If you start using individual
Parts it's uh impossible and then that
challenge that I gave you I really mean
it I I simply
I simply don't see how to do that
without yeah
thank you
yeah a nice question though and and as
you said you you despite being in this
area full force this is the first time
you're seeing double depth research
which is a travesty because it's such a
powerful I mean death research everybody
knows for decades right I mean these are
what we grew up with
and without knowing or at least showing
it to a larger audience what double
refer search is how how is it going to
be its power be used who knows where it
can be used or people you know have many
many very very interesting and
imaginative ways of changing things
around and using it in different places
that has never happened
that was the reason to to give this this
to secret toxic sequence
any other questions
wait let's take this together
foreign